I think it was Beethoven who said that
bah meaning a brook is a misnomer
he really was a sea or an ocean into
which so much music poured and I think
that's a pretty good definition in a way
of the central importance that bajas
played in so many musicians life doesn't
matter whether you're a classical
musician or a jazz musician he's there
he's the one who drew all together he
crystallized the idea of a of an
independent autonomous piece of music
and a music made up of so many different
complex strands a horizontal movement of
melody and rhythm and a vertical
alignment of harmonic progressions and
the harmony that's thereby created by
the counterpoint the interplay of the
voices is what gives us a special
flavour and it's it's both unbelievably
sensuous in Bark's case and also
symbolic of his faith because it's the
symbol of the cross the horizontal and
the vertical alignment of two planes of
sound which creates the cross which in
as a Lutheran was vitally important to
him contrary to the popular image I
think that many people have a bar as
being a bit kind of mathematical and
remote and and severe the music itself
tells you something quite different the
music is complex the music is
mathematical but it has amazing dance
impregnated rhythm and secularity even
when he's writing to the glory of God
there is a sense of kind of secular joy
secular imbalance and effusion in his
writing which makes it so attractive and
it leaps over all the boundaries of of
nationality of date of period and really
it reinforces the idea that this is
music that is for art
I feel is particularly strongly as
regards the the Church cantatas that he
wrote we've got about two hundred of
them there may have been many more but
they've got lost in the in the sands of
time that either word burnt or used as
to light fires or just perished they're
extraordinary pieces because in a way
you could think nothing more irrelevant
to our times because they were written
for a very specific moment in the church
service within the Liturgy of a
parochial liturgy in a provincial town
in Germany and yet there is something
about the way that bar formulates his
music that leaps over all those
obstacles and those divisions and speaks
to us very directly now and I think it's
it's representative of his urgent need
to communicate and to impart his own
feelings not just to be a compliant
servant of the clergy of the church but
to have his own views as to how the
Christian doctrine appeals to him and
also how he thinks it applies to his
fellow man because thus no doubt about
it he puts his own spin on the texts and
that I suppose begs the whole question
of the relationship between music and
text music is not always the compliant
hand servant the maidservant of texts it
can operate according to its own rules
and it can function quite differently
and in counterpoint to the text it's
supposed to be elucidating and never is
is more true in the case of bar where
you know the sermon would be delivered
by the preacher and it would be laying
down the law of the particular theme of
the week which is based on the Gospels
or the Epistle but the moment the
buckets his hands on it he can then
alter the speed of delivery he can alter
the repetitions the emphases the way it
comes over as a rather like a
rhetorician like like somebody who is
giving a speech but a speech in coated
encrusted with with the extra richness
that music brings as a result of the
interplay of all that all the factors of
music the harmony the counterpoint the
polyphony the orchestration the
individual Tambor of instruments the
tessitura
all these things which make it
incredibly rich and a highly developed
form of human utterance